did you know Intel processors brought
personal computers to the home
totally and then Intel made them more
efficient so that you could fit all this
into a laptop tight real tight and then
they help bring Wi-Fi to everybody and
now Intel's best processor ever is here
which helps pcs do things you never
thought possible like time travel Hey
these pants are timeless introducing
Intel's new 6th generation Core
processor it's our best processor ever
the earth is 71% ocean the amount of
organisms that are there it's stunning
their adaptations are inspiring all
kinds of new biomimetic inventions your
new kitchen cabinets might have a glue
that was inspired by muscles think of
muscles attached to the bottom of your
boat or to appear how is it that they're
able to glue themselves and cure that
glue while it's underwater that's
something we very much would like to do
in things like kitchen cabinets plywood
it's usually put together with glues
that were made with formaldehyde in
order to get this really waterproof
quality and formaldehyde is very toxic
so there was a big search to get away
from that formaldehyde that search ended
in the ocean looking at muscles that
glue themselves to peers into the bottom
of your boat using a very particular
kind of chemistry the largest hardwood
plywood manufacturer in the u.s. is
mimicking the recipe from the muscle in
order to put its cabinets together we
actually learned how to glue something
under water from that muscle that's on
the bottom of your boat
to learn more about biomimicry subscribe
to the wired Channel